can i can i can i lovingly hold your
feet to the fire on
a on a uh contention that you made
on elsewhere here on your channel with
us
as your honored guest you made a
statement that i think is fundamentally
not correct
um and i'm curious to hear you defend it
you said that you think
at least in the case of publicly traded
publishers that the customer is never
gamers but is
only the stock market third-party
publishers um
if they are publicly traded yes yeah i
don't think that's the case though
i don't see how you can i don't
understand that statement i wouldn't say
it's all about funding
you said pretty flatly the ultimate
customer of the publisher is the
stockholders
yeah the stuff yeah customer i don't
think that's accurate
because if a publisher is putting out
crap games
you know they may if it's a large and
diverse enough of a portfolio
of games yes they can withstand
short-term
shortfalls and and yes there is some
degree of
like some games are just going to have
an automatic
like a long-running franchise will have
a certain amount of loyalty even as
quality slips but you were kind of going
one extra step is to say
you know the only thing that matters is
the you are referring to something where
i repeatedly said i was generalizing and
being reductive
um so yeah there's nuance to it that i
was like i'm avoiding the nuance to make
the point
um yes it is further than that but like
where ea specifically is concerned
i genuinely believe they're cut their
customer and this is having spoken to
people who left ea
um i think i spoke to maybe seven of
them before i made my first video about
their press conference
uh was that they their their customer
even with their conferences is the
shareholders investors stock market
not actually the gamers so when when
people criticize especially with their
conferences right well yeah when people
criticize their press conferences which
is what sparked me like doing a bunch of
investigation into that specifically um
i reached out to people and was like
why do gamers hate your press
conferences so much and they're like
it's because it's not actually for them
it's part of the bells and whistles of
e3 but it's actually for the investors
uh that's why we don't care that you
don't like them because you're going to
buy fifa and you're going to spend money
on ultimate team anyway
which is true okay that that that's a
fair point that
that i think if you're talking
specifically about who's the audience of
a conference
that i don't actually disagree with you
there it's just i was gonna say what's
wrong with that like that's what that's
honestly what the same thing that apple
does that's that's what that that's for
their shareholders that's for
when you when you're that point yeah
no i interrupt you sorry i was gonna say
the broader point of like that
um a publicly owned company's primary
customer
is the shareholders that is true like
ultimately
you you're obviously your shareholders
will judge you based on your
profitability
and one of the factors on your
profitability will be if the audience is
into what you're doing but like yeah
you're not selling games you're selling
stock
at that scale pretty much yeah right i i
just don't think so because your stock
will not have value
unless the games themselves have value
so while that is true
generally things being negatively
received from you know following
patterns of this
it doesn't tend to have a huge influence
on the stock market and and has a little
bit more recently and there are dips
here and there it did with with
cyberpunk
uh but for the most part because gamers
pre-order things and buy them day one
without waiting for reviews
so consistently it doesn't really matter
if they get poor reviews or even poorly
received because they've already bought
them
in the millions six months before they
even came out but that's
that was so much i would like to know
just just quickly i would like to know
what is with without having earnings
reports and and
and information that you're privy to as
only a shareholder unless you are a
shareholder then you are probably those
things
what information is is supporting
that i want to say notion but
it's it's a that's an indictment so like
what
besides just saying this is what i've
heard this is what i've found out it's
like
you have to be able to i mean there's
people that study the stock market so
how do
how have you so like hey the stock goes
up sorry it's just how businesses
function is if you're a publicly traded
company that is what you care about but
b
i have interviewed like several
first-hand sources about this particular
thing
like like loads of them i would say i've
done a fair amount of research into it
uh before saying anything super
definitive about it that was the thing
that i did at ign
i've got some great proof i've got some
great external proof sure if you want us
if you want to see the stock if you want
to see ea make money
and sorry let's let's generalize it i
don't want to talk about yeah yeah you
want to see
a publish a third-party publisher make
money don't look for the game launch
look for the purchase of the company
that does the thing that the stock
market thinks has value
that's when their stock's going to jump
up it's not to do necessarily
selling fifa great it's successful
that's awesome but the stock doesn't
shift much
it shifts in a predictable fashion but
uh uh let's use the air sometimes those
are really good
if you look at nintendo stuff was
announced skyrocket not when it came out
pop cap this is not that these companies
uh
so so basically a stock the stock market
wants companies to show growth and grow
well crucially they want to show growth
potential
they want to show that this company is
going to make more money over time
and that's that's the thing so when when
when an e3 is
a good illustration of this but it's
it's generalized the
the the press conference at e3 is trying
to show
hey guys we're going to grow in the next
few years we are going to
dominate this market we have these ips
we have we're
moving into every time they announce a
mobile game at e3 right
that's specifically to demonstrate to
that to the stock market that they are
moving in the area where
popularity isn't money is it's one
reason we talked about fortnight the
other day and it's kind of impact
on aesthetics that is partially down to
well largely is down to the fact that
consumers have shown an interest in that
aesthetic
but it's also for all the people who own
stock in the companies making those
cartoony games
that know that games that sell well look
like fortnight right now
so it's kind of you're you're playing to
that crowd with those choices as well
and that's an intentional thing
and as a game developer i'm i i
obviously we're not publicly traded but
we
we certainly work with publicly traded
companies and we certainly pitch to
publicly trade companies
of course that factors in and
understanding that they have to look
good to their shareholders
is ultimately i'm almost in a weird way
my if i'm working if i'm trying to
partner up with a publicly traded
company
my customer is their shareholder right
i'm kind of pitching through them at
their shelter
i need to demonstrate to the person i'm
pitching to that the thing i'm pitching
to them is going to appeal to that
shareholder as much as i'm trying to
pitch they will find a customer
it's about how you look and appear look
at look but it's predicated
on businessmen who've had amazing
careers and become president based on
perception
not on a literal bank account you know
it's it's a it's a
there's a trade there there's a trade
but the the belief in you
the shareholder downstream of the
publicly traded company that you're
pitching to
if they roll that dice it's
an and decide to make a deal with you it
is predicated on the idea that your game
will sell so it's like at the end of the
day the gamers are still necessarily
even
not necessarily like genuinely i'm not
going to talk about specific deals or
anything but like
it's also about the perception it's also
about what the
you know when when um what's a good
example of this look at something like
and back in the day obviously they've
they've now been bought and sold
but like fox searchlight you know was
making these indie movies that were
specifically designed
to win awards right or to be up and
coming find new talent all of this stuff
they were not there to make money they
were there to look
good and that appeal was made to like
enhance the brand
and the to the shareholders ultimately
like and to do that so
no sometimes you're not even there to
make money you're there to create an
illusion of
success that is a fair point actually
for the the the far
like but it's it's a it must be taken in
the context of
foxes meanwhile making
you know x-men and alien and and other
and simpsons episodes and things that
were designed to
to essentially float those fox
searchlight projects
did i lose mike bethel was receiving i
just lost all of austin's audio i'm
poor mike has been very off mic today
that's true
i don't think i'm observing this
conversation
and i don't have a position um simply
because i
i'm enjoying the the information uh and
i'm processing the information
i do hear a lot of intention that
is impossible to intuit
you you can you i'm hearing what what
they wanted
and what they were trying to project and
what was important
you mean you're hearing projection of
intention without
demonstration true true like like i'm
i'm i'm hearing an announcement over a
projectile
just said that like the people who work
there think this right
so they're they're if they're if
anyone's projecting it's the people who
are
like in role senior roles or publishers
are making that presumption
if if there's yeah but again there's
like uh
president of fox comes out and says that
we want to create fox searchlight
pictures so that we can make our
shareholders happy so that we look like
we win awards
um and if that's true it's like well
that yeah that's a pretty clear-cut
thing i
i again i i'm not privy to this i am
curious
because there is a lot of talking like
mike you're you're specifically talking
about hey as a game developer
i've been privy to these conversations
i've been privy to these rooms
so i understand that this is the trend
because we
for right over wrong we base our
companies kind of vision casting up
based upon this
but i i do want to know
alana do you feel a
and i i say this with all sincerity that
because i genuinely do want to
understand
do you feel the moral obligation to say
that as a disclaimer that you
are not an economist or someone who
provides financial planning or
do you know what i mean because that
there's a lot she's reporting on other
people
she's not stating that it's her own
advice she's saying that's not advice
but you are saying this is the way that
these things function this is the reason
why this is how this happens this is the
the economics
of video games what i say when i've
spoken about this and i've spoken about
it a couple of times is generally like
do not listen to me where it comes to
like what stocks you should buy in i'm
not a person you should listen to about
that kind of thing as someone who does
not have experience in that
but if i'm reporting something that i
spent effectively like a full two years
making sure that i focused on as a
journalist
no because i'm just telling you what
i've learned as a journalist
um but i just i i hear that
what i guess what i'm asking is you're
making a very broad statement about
how the the economics of the stock
market
work and that's a very like actually
hold on hold on this isn't an attack i'm
asking you guys
no you're fine um look i feel like the
way that that the stock market works i
i feel like this is a very easy thing to
understand and i'm not making a broad
statement i feel like what i'm saying is
like
very standard information is that
if you're a publicly traded company you
try to make money from the stock market
like i feel like that's just like
any i would think anyone who works in
that field would be like well i mean
reductive and
you know there's like a lot of
qualifiers there but i mean yeah
that's true uh i don't feel like i'm
saying something that is in any way like
hidden from anyone
it's just something that i think gamers
don't think again it was it was a it was
a
there was a lot of like there's a
lot of technical and very specific
jargon and statements that were being
made and i genuinely
want to know because i feel like i learn
more about you and i learn i learn more
about
kind of like your world view and i could
probably become more informed myself
about it very technical
i think if someone who weren't
economists they'd be like you were so
[ __ ] broad just now and i'd be like
yeah
you do say that in the video that i'm
that i'm mentioning that you published
the other day i
i only took issue with the idea and i
could be wrong also
i'm certainly no expert i have zero
invested in the stock market i
am it is not part of my my day-to-day
life in any way
um but i have spent a little bit of time
learning the underlying mechanisms and
it and it really is
for how complex these these markets and
the in the various
ways that they are connected to each
other can get
it is actually fundamentally simple at
its heart because if you are a publicly
traded publisher
part of the reason to have a diverse
offering of
games from mobile games to boutique
indies that you're shepherding to giant
massive
games of service to big aaa premium
games the whole point of that is that if
one or even several of those
fail in succession uh your company can
stand on its feet and if your stock
market is not adversely affected
your stock value is not adversely
affected by a failure of a game
it's because of shareholder belief that
this one failure is not
because because of a systemic issue in
your ability to make
good games and so at the end of the day
the gamer is still
the ultimate uh
uh a signer of value because at the end
of the day if they stop
coming if they stop buying your games
the the stock market
will punish the company i don't disagree
with you mcdonald's isn't yeah they just
sorry
please keep buying them so like the the
fact that like you know
you say that but i it's because people
like them
like that's the thing but that's the
part that like is kind of i'm not
i'm not even talking about it in a in a
like genuine one-to-one conversation way
like it's spoken about in like a
why does cole does activision keep
making this call of duty game that i
hate every year that i will talk about
how much i hate every year like they
have to listen to me but then you buy it
every single year
like that's kind of more the point that
i'm making is that like the words you're
screaming on the internet don't matter
because you are all still buying the
thing and it is still satisfying the
stock market regardless
well that's the customer in terms of
do what i want you are the customer in
terms of
you're going to keep buying it anyway i
think it's an important thing the
shareholders are the boss they're not
the customer they're the ones that are
actually making the decisions so i think
let let me try a semantic change to make
this maybe a little bit more because i
have to because i think i think so what
alana's saying is
sorry well i think alana's saying alana
can say what she's what she's actually
saying
my read of what alana's saying is i
think you're taking important to mean
like
most special or most wonderful
ultimately i think it means ultimate
the ultimate customer of a publisher or
any publicly traded company the ultimate
customer is the shareholder the ultimate
ultimately you you're you're you're
trying to convince that customer
via metrics and austin said a very
important thing he said the word belief
which is entirely core there's a really
here we go
book recommendations sapiens it say yeah
dude
i've got it right over there
specifically draws a line
only mike is allowed to reference uh
books in the back of the phrase
trademark um sapiens references like
that basically draws a direct line
between like
ancient religion and the stock market
and business in general
contracts don't exist contracts aren't a
real thing we all just agree that they
exist and therefore they do like
ultimately there's no magical value to a
contract
unless you live in a society that
enforces and responds to that belief
and stocks you live in a society there
you go got it got it
the um and and stocks are the same it's
a belief-based system
ultimately your currency as a company
so your ultimate customer your final
customer the customer that ultimately
decides how much value your company has
is the stock market in order to
convince them that is the shareholder
not the stock market
sorry apologies are absolutely right the
shareholder although the stock market in
general
anyway um you're you're that's your
ultimate customer
the the customer who buys the game who
is massively important obviously for the
exact reasons austin's saying
is essentially on some level the metric
which drives your share value
um is how successful you are at selling
things defines that
but ultimately the thing you're selling
is shares and therefore your final
customer your ultimate customer
is that's my point yes in mind okay
i mean maybe i'm getting tripped up on
the semantics of it but it just seems
that the the the
shareholder the shareholder no exists
entirely in semantics like that's the
brilliance of all of these things
it's extremely reductive and semantic
yes i just don't see
why the the shareholders will jump ship
if the gamers stop
coming that at the end of the day that
isn't that is just an axiomatic fact
that's correct
so they are the ultimate they are the
end of the they are the end destination
at the end of the line yeah the players
the point that i'm
trying to make is because the players
have the final say
is what is my point but they aren't the
final
mata like it's you're doing things
for players to buy things sure but it's
really just to please the stock market
you don't put micro transactions in a
game because players want it
you know the online rhetoric that they
don't you put them in there for the
stock market but this game is like why
won't you listen to us we hate them
they're like well because it's not for
you
clearly think of it this way austin who
defines the person who the people who
define how much money is in my company's
bank account
is players right like ultimately like if
they buy the game i get money that's how
it works
but the second the company in my bank
account is defined by how much shares
cost
which is defined by how many people are
buying my shares that's how many people
are selling my shares
then the person who defines what's in my
bank account is the shareholders
but that's not true because your revenue
is still overwhelmingly
the players like your but my revenue
isn't the value of my company
well okay true yes but that that i don't
see how that undermines
my quibble here and the funny thing is
that i i'm basically 95
in agreement with you it just feels like
you're putting the shareholder in a in a
in a position of primacy in the
importance of like the executives of the
publicly traded company
over the player and i feel like any
company that
plans to survive other than some kind of
short-term hype
cannot uh put their actual customer
below their shareholder
well to be clear this isn't about how
much we like the customer or how much we
think that these publishers
if you go to any major publisher the
people actually making the decisions
by and large are people who like video
games like at the
the mid to low level at the highest
levels maybe that kind of starts to fade
away a little bit but
like no one's saying that people don't
care about the customers of course they
do
um no one gets into games to make money
exclusively because there's many many
more
profitable ways to make money than
making video games but
yeah it's i think i think yeah i think
this is a semantic argument to be honest
i think i think most of the audience is
probably just like wanting us to stop
yeah this was such a great episode until
the very last second yeah
well i do feel like the stock market is
er
more important than the customer to a
business in capitalism
overall however um i think
unless i edited it out i did say in that
video as well that like on the dev level
the people who are making creative
decisions
definitely care about the people you did
say that yeah oh of course yeah no
not all of them it's it's definitely
like i'd even say like the producer
level
yeah the production like the people who
are involved in the studios
i think the publishers are the ones that
feel differently
that's a there's a lot of broad sweeping
yes
correct that are that are um
the important note is also um which i
feel like i also probably mentioned but
people still ask is it this doesn't
necessarily apply to first parties
uh because they're trying to sell
hardware as well so it's like an
entirely different ballgame for the
people who are trying to sell hardware
that's a whole other approach to a
business they can do very very very
different things
i just always i guess i i would always
compare
like look you know an easy and easy
example would be look at a company like
yahoo
you know if they if they s their their
their stock price today
is a is a pale reflection of what it
once was
a couple of decades ago and if they
had basically kept
their customer base and they had they
had done a lot of things differently and
hadn't lost their market share to
google and whoever else then their stock
market
value would not have declined 100
percent agree with you also
that is that you have to keep human
users are ultimately
what drove people to sell off their
shares of yahoo and thus its value went
down
right it strikes me as very simple and
how would that be different for ea
if if you know if or like look at
activision if call of duty stops selling
like gangbusters and i saw that cold war
they said was the highest selling of all
call of duties like
if they weren't continuing to make games
that people in droves were willing to
buy
then there they they they would see the
same decline it just
it's just not instantaneous feedback i
would also ask a question
that you made a statement where you said
that the
the goal is to not sell i'm paraphrasing
slightly but the goal is not to sell
video games but it is to sell shares is
that is that correct
or well for your shares to have higher
value that's there's a
huge huge difference though between them
there's a huge difference again that's a
massive
because i don't necessarily want to sell
if i had a company i wouldn't want to
sell multiple shares because now i have
multiple shareholders and i have
less control less equity in my company
but always talk about public yeah but a
publicly even a publicly traded company
it's not so much about how many shares
you have sold it is the value of that
share
so it's not about i want to share we
want you want the shares to sell because
that will increase their value
you you might be wanting i'm not saying
it's not true
well no i think you're misunderstanding
where i'm coming i'm not saying that i
is the person who
owns the company want to sell more
shares i'm saying i want other people to
be selling my shares back and forth to
increase the value that's what i'm
saying okay
yeah i just said yeah it's between
others it's not for i yeah i don't wanna
i don't wanna deprecate my value
obviously in that name
all right but it's but i guess that's
the yeah the value of the share will
also the scarcity of that share will
also determine the value of it
so it's it's not in the sense of you
never want to like have the
the price of a game go up right so
there's a significant difference and i
think comparing
shareholders to customers and and shares
to
copies of games is is just
it's a totally you say it's a different
game if it's hardware it's a totally
different game
the shareholder is ultimately the boss
that is that i i believe that to be
true because there's no one that's ever
in charge
and ultimately it is it is it's this
snake eating its own
tail because the shareholders at the top
of the chain
according to the shareholder but the
customers according to the is
at the top of the chain according to the
customer and the dev is at the top of
the ship now dev never fills
all of these on paper are great all of
them
the problem is is a lot of made a
statement at the very
beginning is humans have bias and that's
true and that's that's
ultimately if i'm hungry i'm going to
eat first
um or if i think the only place me and
alana are disagreeing with you guys is
that
a certain kind of so a certain kind of
like big corp
if you're if you're a big company you're
wait what's the what's the thing they
say about the internet that if you're
not paying for it then you're not the
customer
you are the yeah right yeah instagram is
free because they sell your data and ads
and you know what if you're only paying
if you're if you cut to an extent if
you're only paying 60
a year for a video game you're not the
customer you're the product you're the
proof of that product success
a financial center for the company
rather than
and you know individually you're
absolutely right if the entire world
decided they didn't want to play call of
duty that would have an enormous effect
but the entire world's not going to
decide that but the reason is because
it's a good game that's my that's my
that's all i keep saying it's it's not
so i
like that that's the way though that
yeah so this is the one part that i like
i feel like that i've focused on that
um i maybe haven't expressed well enough
is that i'm i'm very specifically
like trying to explain something to
people who feel like they keep
complaining about something keep being
like
why do you keep announcing release dates
too early why do you keep doing this
like why is call of duty doing this
thing that i don't like every year and
they're like why won't they listen to us
it's because you can say that all you
want but for as long as you keep buying
the game which they keep
doing it doesn't matter to them like you
don't matter
where that is concerned as long as you
keep buying the thing
because it's a publicly traded company
it's a lot bigger than than your
feedback so i'm trying to
share value yeah yeah the share value
goes up more from the announcement
probably than the sale in most cases
so that's why because i remember
specifically we knew when they were
going to drop new hardware
and i went to my i definitely happened
with pokemon go
what it was yeah i was going to say it's
like do i have will there be any
financial gain if i were to buy stock
before
i know this thing is going to hit call
of duty is going to hit or whatever that
would be inside of trading
no i had to sign a thing saying that i
would not buy stocks in uh
nintendo slash pokemon you're getting
you're making a lot of broad
statements well yes yes this is broad
so the the the person that has
gone to school specifically for this and
is accredited and licensed to be able to
sell stocks told me that it wasn't
so it wasn't insider trading however the
point of it was saying
that it wouldn't it wouldn't make a
difference he was like you need to be
way way way down the line it's it's not
just because this thing
is about to it launches on the 11th or
whatever it's announced on this date or
whatever that's not when you buy the
stock
that's that's he goes you're you're
you're you're sorry
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so it's because
as mike pointed out or
one of one of you i think it was mike
that that is
these are these stock prices are
entirely about perception of value i
mean that's what all
that's what all price is in all of
humanity can we not learn anything from
gamestop i mean [ __ ]
yeah yeah exactly so it's all an
illusion oh i'll say
well it's not it it's just it's just
created by very
tangible real it's just a lie agreed
upon our paper the
the cash that i have yeah that's a
better way of putting a lawyer yeah
bitcoin the uh the thing you're the one
that's amazing the um the only
the only uh alana just now a moment ago
when you were explaining why you were
explaining this you you you
uh kind of applied monolithic attributes
to a
heterogeneous group because you said we
complain about this
yet why do they keep doing it and i
think the reason for that
correct me if you disagree is because
the people who go online and say why are
they doing these release dates why are
they giving us these games
you are not wrong to say that this isn't
for you it's because
the people the 20 million other people
who go and buy the game aren't making
those complaints it's it's basically the
one percent twitter mob says this but 99
of customers do something different well
it's better than that right it's that
not only are they also buying it but
also if you see you've seen the meme
right of the
well it was years ago the call of duty
uh we're not buying call of duty steam
group
and on launch day they're all by playing
call of duty
so yeah austin you are right that it is
all of the other gamers who still buy
the thing
um that that contribute to that but
like it's it's that my point of
of saying that is directed at those very
specific people who are like why do they
do this gamers don't want it
um and yes it is monolithic like that
not you know i i always feel like
the amount of gamers who actually even
know who
ea are necessarily like really know what
they do when they're a fifa player
ears like probably not that big like i
don't know how many people who play
video games are like super into video
games like the amount of people who
played the last of us part two and never
even heard of the leaks
is probably tremendously high and like
there are things on the internet that
you feel are way bigger than they
necessarily are and i always feel like
that's the thing with video games is
that we have to remember that
not everyone actually knows absolutely
everything there are so many people who
just buy video games
and aren't on twitter like that's a huge
part of it but it is essentially just
something that i'm directing very
specifically to people who say we
they're gamers all of us millions of us
aren't being listened to why don't they
care why did they announce a release
date and and the point is release dates
like which was the point of that video
specifically
are often dictated by marketing teams
and and shareholders rather than
is that inherently a bad thing i'm just
trying to understand for you
is that are you making just like an
observation without
having any kind of position on it or
you're saying
i feel like a customer is the
shareholder and i feel that that is bad
well i mean
i'm not trying to give any opinion on it
whatsoever i think it is bad but i
i that's also very very late i've not
tried to give any opinion on it at all
just
to be like this is an observation yeah
i'm not trying to
put any negative connotation in there
with that conversation at all
do you feel that the connotation of the
bias is inherent though because you're
sure but i'm not pushing it i'm not
trying to do that
um yeah why is it bad just just so i
understand
well i'm if i'm saying that i'm trying
to just give an observation and not give
a negative
connotation it's because i'm trying not
to do that because
you don't have an obligation to anybody
now to you did this for something for
ign right so
but why well generally i would think
that uh creatives being pressured by a
stock market
especially especially in the case of
cyberpunk um
if that game had been given more time
they could have realized a lot of the
things that they promised they could
have polished a lot of things uh the
devs at the studio had specifically said
that they you know wanted to do things
differently but
the upper management uh essentially made
the game come out like that that's
that's an example of why i think it's
bad is that the creatives are not being
listened to and
releasing the product that they want to
and i think that sucks
launch dates are affected by margin
calls and
quarterly reports and stuff like that
yeah that's
what your financial year is all that job
cdpr is actually a pretty good example
of
what i was saying where that in contrast
to an aaea
uh they are effectively a single game
studio
um you know it's like if cyberpunk
crashes and burns their stock market
is their stock value rather is going to
take a massive hit interestingly
games still sold incredibly well like
very very i don't doubt that
same thing last of us right even after
the um
returns sold very well but their stocks
did go down
because of belief yep the belief went
down and i think that
but crucially not the belief in the
gamers although that
influenced it but the belief in the
shareholders needs to go down in order
for it to make a difference not how much
money people actually spend that strikes
me
so very well that strikes me as as just
shareholders
i mean that's right versus people that
are trading in it
what what well the their set so the
stock would the stock value would go
down if enough shareholders were selling
off
again very simplified but like that
would be the so it would you'd be losing
the faith of shareholders if your stock
went down in value
but there's also a million other things
so i'm not going to completely commit to
that statement because as you say it's
very complicated
but like that's yeah that would be the
the presumption i would be going in with
that yes they've lost some the faith of
a lot of shareholders for the stockton i
don't
see what's bad cdpr is a publicly traded
company
yeah yeah i don't i don't see what's bad
about that because if the company
bungles the release
then i think it's a positive yeah like
they they they should be
like as much as i love the people that i
know there and as much as i know that
the development
you know the 800 some odd developers
worked their ass off and and
were you know just in the shittiest
situation my heart goes out to them like
it sends a strong message to management
if you're going to make a game this way
and it comes out and
and it has all these problems like i as
a shareholder
i'm like thank you very much goodbye
that that seems like that's
a third party publisher that was part of
why i wanted to make that video
who very specifically said that they
felt like
the situation with uh cyberpunk and
the effects on the stock market would
give them a better case uh to their
publisher going forward and that they
were really happy that they had it in
stone now that they could present that
to their publisher and be like see this
stuff maybe does matter
can we delay our game if we need to and
that was like a really pointed thing
that i was like oh [ __ ] you actually
have that yeah that's that's
a great change oh my god i'm also that's
the system working
because you brought up the fact that a
lot of people are just kind of like all
i know is video games
right they're not necessarily i'm big
gamers i really believe in this industry
they're just like
it's a commodity to them they understand
that video games are a place to be
investing in that's why they buy that
buy that stock i was interested because
i didn't realize that senior project was
a
publicly traded company that was that
was surprising to me but said by
september 17th it was the largest
publicly traded video game company in
poland
making it the largest video game
industry company in europe
ahead of ubisoft so if you become
the largest of something are you not
going to maybe
suffer as the as the industry goes
well so let's say that ubisoft um
has a [ __ ] year or whatever and their
their sales go down their stock goes
down
does rising tide float and and therefore
sink all boats
if you're the largest i would think that
outside of my skill set like i
definitely don't
know the yeah like if tech stocks go
down
all tech stocks go down it's not just
one specific company
definitely
there's multiple types of investors
obviously because investors are just
people there's a million there's as
many types of investors as there are
human beings in the markets and i think
that
there are some that like you said
they're gonna go i should be in video
games that's making a lot of money and
they're not like researching they don't
know the difference between how
epic is running fortnite versus
administering the epic store
and how you know like i have no idea
okay and this and that yeah they're just
like some financial advisor said well
we're gonna pick up some video game
stocks and then they go oh
there's some bumps in the road we should
maybe get out of video games that's
gonna be one type of investor and
another type of investor is gonna be
someone like us who knows a lot about
these individual companies and maybe far
more they know who's the ceo
who who was recently recruited to be the
cfo
of ea and this and that and they're like
hard in on this stuff and they
they still may not be even gamers but
they just understand this
particular market and and i would think
yeah the the casual ones
if there's a if there's choppy waters
they're gonna be like i don't know about
i don't know about games maybe this
isn't
for me i'm sure that i own some kind of
pharmaceutical stock i have no interest
or understanding of pharmaceuticals
that's this that's because
my profile says that i want to have this
much growth
by this much time until my guy goes then
we invest in this stock for right now
and i can move
but that's that's exactly what it's
supposed to do it use wherever
those crops are growing is where you're
invested where you're seeded
it's no different than folks you know i
mean that that
those kind of aggregated over
generalizations happen in every
conceivable way you could have
you could have people saying you know i
want to go live in x
country right now because i believe in
it even if their country's undergoing
unbelievable amounts of tumultuousness
if you get down into the nitty-gritty
because there's still a broad perception
of it being a good
place to go and or vice versa that
there's you know
this one person is doing very very well
but overall maybe
a lot of people are bailing out like it
it's just that's just symptomatic of
just the complexity of
life it's fair
it doesn't we have been extremely broad
across the board yes
thank you very much i i just i i do i do
um i understand what you're taking issue
with dustin and i feel like maybe it's
it's just coming from um my point is
directed at explaining things to people
who don't understand why did this
company do this
uh that that is but you can only explain
it to a certain extent very broadly
without any nuance or any
room for yeah and in a lot of years
in defending you it was like a ten
minute video it was one of those here
was the story
i was walking into ralph's and i i was
like i'm gonna be in here for like 10
minutes and my youtube notifications was
like here's a 10 minute video and i was
like i'm going to listen to this while
i'm at ralph's
and if your video had been like 20
minutes long i would i would have looked
for a 10 minutes we've
talked about it longer than the video
yeah
and and everything that you're saying
here i i i i
so either i i i don't disagree with the
end of that sentence what i was
my summary and then i will shut up is
that i
possibly misunderstood your intent and
or possibly you were being brought and i
just was projecting that i wanted you to
be more specific because i
my takeaway that i found um
eyebrow raising was the idea that
all that matters to a publicly traded
third-party publisher is their stock
value and that
that the quality of their games and the
interest of players to buy those games
essentially doesn't matter did she say
that wasn't did you say it was most she
said it was the most
the most important customer not the only
customer right well i just remember the
sentence
it was specific the shareholder is the
customer yeah
specifically in regard to release dates
it was and and and like delaying them it
was very specific
that yeah fair point fair point
uh yeah that that to me i and i may have
i may have
missed the force for the trees uh in the
fact that i was like looking at bananas
when you said it
like i presented anything perfectly but
like to troy's point yeah it is
it was extremely broad i'm gonna need
you to present things perfectly because
i want people to understand it i don't
want to make a two-hour video that
people aren't going to watch
so it's got to be like a short concise
one
10 minutes we're waiting at the store
otherwise austin's going to move on
here that's true
this this was the topic because we
didn't want to avoid being too
quick and dirty this podcast
demonstrates that people
will watch nonsense you also just
demonstrate the exact same thing that
the shareholders do what's that
you you made something that was
palatable and easy to share for the
people that you want as opposed to
what it could have been you know what i
mean i have no idea what you're saying
sure well i'm glad a
i thought austin.exe has crashed no i
said sure like yeah i made something
short i don't know how the stock
market's doing that but
um i definitely did make something
intentionally short and to a point
for people who've not heard the point
before yes
for the record even if i found myself
what's that even for
for for this right even if i may have
even if i may have uh disagreed and or
or found it
uh uh curious and if uh if that
curiosity
mike well if that curiosity raises
actually the human connection
if that was based on a misunderstanding
of your point i'll have you know it was
a fabulous
uh accompaniment to my looking
uh who knows it's a fabulous
accompaniment to
choosing uh baguette and and bananas and
and
the various things that it accompanied
me i like that way better than apples
and oranges
baguettes and bananas [ __ ] yeah i'm
stealing that
[Laughter]
damn it if there's one thing we take
away from this conversation yes
baguettes
that's going to be the title of this
episode baggage against bananas i could
split this one into two though that's
you know
sometimes i think that maybe that's what
we're gonna split into two i've got
another five minutes so it's two
completely different conversations
i don't know it is two totally different
conversations
yeah that my fault my sorry about that
dm someone the phrase screw mike and
they've sent me photographic evidence of
it austin do you care
to comment on this there we go we're
competing for a friend's extra ps5
that's hilarious he he goes screw myself
is austin's take on this screwball
that's i love that he screenshotted that
that's
fantastic i know who my confidant is
no no no no so yeah that was the funny
thing and neither does mike and and i
saw
mike tweet that earlier and a friend of
mine uh
messages me and goes so mike's
trustworthy right
should i send him my ps5 and i went what
no i want one to hell with him
and i love that interesting it's all
part of
something i do think it's interesting
interesting this is one thing i wanted
to get into with
so funny so calling him after this
state of play of the day was that it
seemed like it was really showing off
the hardware
which seemed a little unfair because
it's a little bit cruel
yeah it's like you can't it showing off
the hardware is great but either you're
making the people who've bought one feel
better about it
but you're you can't sell any more it's
so it's not like you have to like you
really should go and buy a ps5 right now
that everyone's like i know
they're trying to so that's why i didn't
understand them doing it
even for even shareholders and customers
alike i'm like that's a that's a long
term
thing like when i uh i got sponsored by
vidya to get a
uh they gave me a 3080 and people were
like why would they do this when i could
buy one do they not want customers like
well it's marketing allocation so
they're given one for the long-term
market so that when you can get one
you'll still buy one
but that's all been eaten up by bitcoin
too
it's full circles thank you by bitcoin
it's the
worst oh it's the worst did we not talk
about that
about the the guy who has like 12 000
gpus to just generate bitcoin
every year who looks at the world right
now and goes we need to incentivize more
power usage
yeah it's pretty much um power like
actual like electricity oh my god
i didn't i didn't realize the electrical
topic um yeah so like
the uh amount of power
that bitcoin uses um just for mining
is like disgusting but i've heard that
i've heard that that because of that
it's it's not really it's barely if
it's all profitable for the miner isn't
that like like this
it is all times capitalism it only has
to be ever so slightly profitable right
it doesn't have to be very profitable
yeah so there's a guy who is crypto
mining with 78 geforce rtx 3080 gpus and
makes about 150
000 a year except well mike wait wait
you say welcome to capitalism
there will always be a greater incentive
to things that have better margins
because there's an opportunity cost of
choosing a versus b and if i
only stand to make a tiny profit doing a
then we wouldn't have any low profit
uh industries no it just means that the
opportunity cost
was acceptable
like people still do things because they
have passion for them and
their ability to continue to do so is
predicated i think anyone's passionate
towards like
i don't know what's what's what's a low
margin i'm trying to get a low margin
industry
well restaurants restaurant restaurants
is something people are passionate about
no one's passionate about mcdonald's
though necessarily
[ __ ] did you see the founder
did you see the it's true angela and i
have nasty fridays that is literally
like
big macs so much mcdonald's in the last
two months
did you see my name oh i got a giant
nugget
i haven't had mcdonald's in years i'm
gonna let this conversation flow off of
this
no no if you can make a cent
then there'll be a then there'll be
people who pursue that as a business
even if it's the
even if you have to spend a dollar to
make that sense if you have to spend ten
dollars a hundred dollars thousand
dollars
to make that sense someone will be doing
it what what the profit motive does
is it encourages efficient attempts to
try and get two cents
but it doesn't prevent anyone from
trying out if there's a cent to be got
the system encourages you to go and get
that sent you know
i mean yeah i would say okay fine but i
think that
the fact that if it costs you a dollar
to get that scent the very same
incentives would immediately say this is
not working and you will bail
i again like there's not many businesses
like radio still exists as an industry
like
slightly yeah
growing apples like stuff that like very
low profit margin
activities still do well in i don't know
what it's like in the us but here
supermarkets have massively drilled down
uh the the margin you can make basically
it's a kind of
to a de facto monopoly almost where if
you're if you're growing produce to be
sold in supermarkets in the uk
the supermarkets are setting the price
and they're obviously pushing that as
low as they can
so these farmers are getting by on a
tiny margin
um and many i'm sure have left the
industry and
done other things as you say austin but
someone's still making apples you know i
mean like there will always be people
who will
chase that scent and unfortunately with
bitcoin you're not creating anything of
value
you're just using electricity to
generate cash
and that's well and this is where yeah
imagine if it costs like
imagine if like it cost a hundred
dollars to make a one cent
coin like you wouldn't like
it would be awful wouldn't it but if if
but people would still do it
you know sorry to make it would cost it
would cost a hundred dollars to make a
hundred dollars and one cent coin sorry
apologies yeah you have to
make it back but yeah the thing that uh
yeah okay so that yeah well no i just
that distinction you just made is a big
part of what my pushback was because you
were basically
describing a giant loss and calling it
profit yeah you're absolutely right yeah
i know those i misspoke but
but the point is if someone spends so
this guy's making 150
000 a year presumably what's actually
happening is he's spending an enormous
amount of money
losing an enormous sorry spending a lot
of money and then making much more money
and his margin is 150 000
a year so how much electricity is he
using to get to that 150 000
a terrifying amount more than we could
ever use at least with most consumer use
of electronics it is to
uh you know travel create value
go to work feed yourself like look after
yourself like
have fun that's a that's an important
thing like many of those things are very
subjective by the way
yeah they're all subjective but just
general using using
electricity to generate a cash amount
with no products to that labor no
no outcome beyond that yeah that's a
that's a dodgy thing
you're not making anything you're not
contributing you're just generating cash
yeah i guess i guess it's like that it's
like this particular guy i think it
costs him around one thousand five
hundred dollars a month
just for the electricity bill
for the record that's it yeah that's
actually quite i seem quite low
for that very good he's doing it
efficiently i guess yeah well and for
the record
i think it's also like if it's just one
guy or
even if it was a thousand people doing
that it's it's it's
hardly it's different than if we start
talking about tens of millions of people
it's
bigger than some countries now austin
yeah it's let me find an article for you
austin like
the electric the there's there's the
energy usage of bitcoin it's it's like
taking over
for the record i'm not defending that as
somebody who tries to keep his carbon
footprint as low as humanly possible
uh like i i'm i'm all for that uh so i'm
not
i'm not um trying to defend it but i am
i'm trying to yeah
troy's gotta go exactly good example and
i've got i've gotta take it
and i've got and thanks to troy i've got
my matching one so
it's uh it's um i i i'm just trying to
understand it but i'm
trying to understand it while not coming
at it from an ideologically predisposed
to
dislike it perspective that's all that
uh so it sounds like i'm defending it
i'm just trying to make clear i'm not
um yeah i i mostly don't i don't
have a dog in that fight as it were um
for you from really dcaf maybe maybe
bitcoin currently uses
strikes 129 terawatt hours of
electricity
per year where is he based
well okay this is that across the board
like all bitcoin activities aggregated
do what do i
as someone who know what that means you
know my high school yeah my
my high school physics is long behind me
do we have a a a comparison that puts
that number in perspective because this
is where my education reaches its
cliff's edge it's definitely overtaken
some countries i'm forgetting which ones
right now as far as power usage
yeah countries like the vatican city uh
like like no like several times more
than
for example the production of all paper
and coin currency in the world
is a minuscule percentage of this for
obvious reasons right it's cheap to make
money
paper paper's a really good example i
mean the waste produced
to create a piece of paper is is
staggeringly low it's the same thing
with what about this one this is a
really good
paper recycling desalinization of water
is a stupid futile
industry but we're still doing it
because we recognize the fact that this
planet is two-thirds
water and we're going to run out of it's
as a potential we could run out of fresh
water so we better figure out how we can
desalinate water but right now
the output to input is is is laughable
mm-hmm
yeah it's like smaller
damage is energy by industry rather than
the individual most most of the damage
that's done is
and then they're they're serving the
individual but you turning off your
lights has a very tiny effect
to put this in context and answer
questions
very
[Music]
[Laughter]
it would be in the top 30 energy users
worldwide
but here's the question is is not that
for no value at all well but society
this is where i don't know i i don't i
don't i won't take for granted the truth
of that statement
yeah because i just don't know for
example if if it were to replace
like troy just mentioned if it were to
replace or
not just necessarily bitcoin but just
cryptocurrency conceptually if it were
to replace we're into our third episode
now
um the um the manufacturer
of physical currency yeah it seems like
even with
exorbitant electrical usage we would we
would have a net
loss i would think a net loss
if you needed enough bitcoin to replace
worldwide currency
if it became the dollar hell yeah dude
it would go massively it would be the
biggest
energy consumer actually i don't know
the numbers well it would be more than
this right now
but that's also presuming that that's
presuming that the rate of growth would
would stay the same which do we know
that as a given
that the rate of electricity it will so
my understanding of the way it works and
again like you know not an expert
is that it basically gets harder to
generate a bitcoin every bitcoin you
generate sort of it's in it's designed
to prevent inflation essentially that
like them
every time a bitcoin is created or it
doesn't work like this because it's
mountains it's basically
it's harder to make the 100th bitcoin
than the first bit there are a finite
amount
because of moore's law because computers
get faster it's trying to offset that
difference
so no the theory would be that the
energy consumption
would stay the same or get i think that
would be because of the blockchain
uh because the more bitcoin you are
creating that you own the more
the larger the record of the blockchain
is which is you know shared between
however many people um you are you are
creating more data that has to be served
the more
bitcoin you mine or pieces of bitcoin
you might yeah i don't i don't
i don't know enough about it but why but
yeah so yes you're absolutely right
though austin in
theory if the entire world stops having
its own sovereign currencies
and bitcoin was accepted as the only
currency
then theoretically the cost of it could
potentially come down
but it would require world peace at the
same time the thing i like about it
and that might be i would i would
subscribe to that theory that's my
question
if we had one world if we had one
currency is that not better
i don't know well the thing about
bitcoin is probably unlikely to happen
in the next 50 years
the way that bitcoin ties into that is
that the the records are effectively
held by the public rather than by the
banks and i actually feel like that's a
positive like yes if we could reach
that's a good full world bitcoin uh i
would be for it
but it seems very unlikely that we can
do that but we won't will we but there
is also a beauty that
right now america wouldn't want the
dollar to not exist america does very
well from the dollar being the de facto
currency of the
world there's also but there's also a
trade-off to that to where there's guns
over there right you've got like tanks
and [ __ ] like you wouldn't
some of the beauty of that is that as we
saw what happened in the market like if
you had this you are
you are to the wind and waves of of
whatever
that that specific blockchain currency
is but
worse comes to worse my money in the
bank is guaranteed by the federal
government up to a certain amount
so there is that if i have a 250 000 and
one dollar that one dollar is a loss so
it's up to a limit and that was
increased uh from 150 000 to 250 000 i
think in 2008
2009 but i i think there is
that to me is an example of and this is
where i
am not nearly versed enough in economics
to make a claim to be able to no one
thinks we're experts
but what were things for experts well i
just want to make it very clear that i
could be out on a limb
quite dramatically with this statement
but my instinct against
the potency of like a unified global
currency
is precisely the kind of thing that you
just articulated with the fdic
backing of your of your bank uh like the
fdic guarantee of your bank account
would would be that um
there is an inherent competitiveness to
different countries
that um if everything were shared on one
then it meant that the entire thing
could be destroyed and wipe out
essentially everybody in one fell swoop
whereas
whereas you know one country's offering
if another country came along and said
you know we we can offer better
the equivalent of fdic uh guarantees and
this and that and that's and that's how
you end up
it's essentially a form of stock market
in a sense
and that doesn't strike me that doesn't
strike me as a bad thing because it it
it keeps the incentive in protecting the
the company it's still all fictional
right like that's the thing is like you
can have like
you know the euro is a shared currency
between multiple countries it's probably
the closest
is it the only currency that's that's
that widely spread between different
countries surely yeah i don't know
different countries sure the yen would
be like the largest
when the when the when the greek when
the greek economic situation went
terrible it didn't bring down germany
because money is no but didn't it but
didn't it strain the hell out of germany
i'm sure very smart economic economists
worked out how to like manipulate
essentially is its literal manipulation
of the market and the money
to make that not impact which is the
other reason why the uk got out right
is because it was a strain on there were
lots of many
those are that's probably an episode
politically america the uk's
understanding and an interaction with
european europe is a very strange thing
but the
my point is like ultimately um it's all
it's all nonsense it's all fiction so
like it
it doesn't it it it's a it's a lie we
all agree on to
if you can't eat it [ __ ] it or kill it
it really is something that's a product
that's been made
it's like i did get a quote from an
expert where bitcoin is concerned this
is from david gerrard the author of
attack of the 50-foot blockchain who
said bitcoin is literally anti-efficient
so more efficient mining hardware won't
help it'll just be competing against
other efficient mining hardware that
means bitcoin's energy
stack i'm talking yeah and hence it's
co2 production only spirals outwards
it's very bad that all this energy is
being literally wasted on a lottery
which that's the other thing of course
is that it is a lottery it's randomized
it's it's grotesque if you it's like if
you had to like you know
shoot an endangered animal in order to
enter the lottery it's
it's awful it's just like it's morally
they make a very good point that elon
musk has like done all this
you know the pro
just good work with with energy
transitions where tesla is concerned but
then kind of just thrown it all away
by the amount of money that they spent
on bitcoin like tesla
are you saying the profit motive alone
is not enough to make someone act in the
best interest of the world
there's another interest that elon
giving my libertarian card back
i'll be trying to find this quote but
elon musk made more money in one day
by buying bitcoin than he did
making electric cars period which shows
that the structure is perhaps not the
best one right like i think that's
i feel like well there's also there's
also a um like that's probably a broken
system right if that's
which it is i'm sure if that's true
that's a terrible system
in our lives that statement it may be
predicated on the fact that elon musk
has um basically leveraged his whole
if you look up the nature of his
finances
he's basically gambled on tesla where if
the company fails he has no money
whatsoever
uh like it it is it he more
no still to the still to date that's my
understanding he basically he basically
has
in one day i can't find that but i don't
doubt it
well well from bitcoin the bitcoin thing
is something has an estimated one
billion regardless coin
yeah that may be the case i mean he's
done that so he did that with paypal
didn't he as well like i think he's just
been a person who has put a lot of money
into something made a lot of money and
then put a lot of money into the next
thing which
yeah that's the thing i've always
admired about him that he will put his
he will he will bet the farm on
something that he believes in
he is not drawing a salary in the
conventional set like i watched a video
that was basically i think it might have
even been recommended
in our comments of uh in a prior episode
that was a
a look at the difference uh between jeff
bezos and elon musk where elon musk
basically has leveraged his
his total potential net worth in the
future success
of tesla because and as such he has no
salary
um in in stark contrast to jeff bezos i
i find it all just fascinating i'm not
there's no moral judgment for me on that
one way or the other i
just i thought it's possible that the he
made more in a day thing was predicated
on the fact that he draws no salary from
tesla so it's not even
if he'd made a hundred bucks he would
have made more from bitcoin than
from tesla i mean in other words he made
it the veracity of the claim may be
technical
sure yeah i'm just simply pointing out
that it might be it might be kind of
the truth of it is dependent on a kind
of technicality
more i also think that if let's say he
gives a billion dollars right and then
he takes that and he goes
and he builds state of the art
across the globe uh orphanages
and provides clean water to third world
countries and does all this stuff
is it still the worst system imaginable
or is it
bitcoin i'm just i'm just saying period
you're like
any system that would allow for someone
to have that much profitability in a
single day like that can't be good
that's not my argument why it's not good
man of why it's not good is that it
creates that value in a in a way that's
dangerous on a worldwide scale
but it also provides the opportunities
the system is identified sorry to be
clear there were the same number of
people available to build that orphanage
before and after the bitcoin trade
happened
the money is the methodology by which
people came together to do a thing
but the money itself is not ethically or
morally good in this
based on what it's spent on i agree uh
oh yeah i i see what you're saying about
that
those people there was no more good
there was no more availability or
opportunity for that thing to occur
because the money existed we just were
able to pay for it
so it's still the same system has to be
applied to these people going
but the relative value of everything
else went down it's like it's like if
you're
if you've got uh i don't know if you've
got a bowl of water and you've got to
share it between five people
okay if one if if you give more of that
water to one person everyone else has a
bit less right
sure that's ultimately how economics
works money's a way of kind of checking
that's not right have relatives other
people yeah you can't economics is not a
zero-sum game
well wealth is created and it is
definitely not uh
uh there's not a finite amount if that
were true then what do you mean though
like gold being dug out of the earth or
no because the because because it
ultimately falls on what people
uh what value people ascribe to it's
just like our our stock market
conversation where
if i if i if i have this and i think
it's worth a dollar but you really want
it and decide it's worth five
if i you you you can
you have created wealth by finding this
thing valuable in my
no my willingness to pass one we've
we've just taken a mug and moved it from
one person to another no value has been
increased through that process
if the value of this goes up then value
is created
no because you took more from me as a
result of that value going up in my
perception
so i gave you if i gave i swapped you
this uh fidget
toy and this other fidget toy i have so
many of these because of how my brain
works i'm sorry
um but these these things right um
if i was like you know what that red cup
is only worth one fidget toy
and you're like actually it's a really
good cup and i was like okay fine
two fidget toys and you said cool it's
worth that
and i give you the two fidget toys and i
take back the cup there's still only a
cup and two fidget toys it just matters
things are in i agree that that enough
person to create it's from that
transaction
a person a person trans word person
a person-to-person transaction may in
fact be
zero-sum but economies at large are
definitely not
like jobs unless you're digging gold out
of the ground or
having children or like what
all of which happens those are those and
those things happen like but not because
of money
i think i never said because of money
i'm just saying if
if the world were zero sum then the
economic state of the world would be
identical to when we were killed the
world is literally zero sum unless a
meteorite lands on it
like we have like a finite amount of
okay yes but but it is that that that is
to true technically speaking although
the the resource consumption depending
on the resources
were so nowhere near the the the
the you know give you sunlight sunlight
is a resource that comes in
actually that's a finite an exhaustive
exhaustible source
yeah it's also finite that's what i mean
my point is my point is the
the elon musk being richer doesn't make
the earth richer
as a result of that or even if you don't
hey of course i have no disagreement
with that
that's not what i'm saying this is a
fascinating perception because you're
absolutely i
see what you're saying where it's like
we're not creating
water right
i mean i might it's with a long call
afterwards i think i'll go and create
some water
i'm with you actually i'm with you on
that one right now
i got a real
no water transfers around the planet
yeah there's no new water
being made except from through
chemical reactions where the water is
being created as the outcome of a
chemical reaction
but then it's still coming from the
constitution
if you take it to if you take it to the
like yes there is only
one way now as it weighed
i don't know if this is true twenty
thousand years ago a million years ago
billions
we're the same amount of matter floating
around the sun now
this is such a like reduction though
like conversation
what i think it might be unless we
well we do we do blast off atmosphere
into space because we are blasting off
atmosphere so that would ruin the whole
argument
let's let's stay come on we are not a we
are not a closed system even just
the earth the earth radiates radiation
well that's the thing that's what i mean
by my
first episode of playlists
that's what we cut out earlier when we
did that big car by the way
it looks like for the four of us to get
stoned together this is
pretty much it my
my earth mass argument is flawed but in
terms of where it's bollocks that's why
it's flawed
but the the point remains that the
movement of finances around the planet
does not have any impact on the value of
the objects and the world and the people
on the planet
now let's talk about time what is it is
time real this time
well look i i i am i am in no small part
due to the
aforementioned biology i i am
i'm being perhaps uh quick and
messy um and i'm also not an economist
as has been
repeatedly stated um yeah
surely
but i i do think that we can one can
discuss the non-zero-sum nature of
markets without having to go to the
reductio absurdum of well we only
there's only one universe there's a
finite number of atoms in the universe
like well we were talking about value
creation via bitcoin that's where we
started with this many years ago
and but and that was that is an argument
that is about literal using earth
resources
to generate cash value and it
by definition by my definition that is a
simply a reduction of
earth resources that is not a production
of
new value that's that that was the
that's why we went there
because we were talking essentially
about a very simple transaction between
fair enough can i get one whatever and
what you just and what you bridge
now let's talk about jesus i'll just add
just add and then i'm going to shut up
for the rest of the year we can see the
floor i i just will say what you just
said about specifically bitcoin and the
use of
that i find again while bathed in
ignorance about bitcoin and how it works
i find what you say very agreeable
intuitively i don't
i don't nothing about what you're saying
strikes me as wrong i just don't see it
as
emblematic of of the issue with um
markets conceptually uh but that's
i don't have a problem with markets
conceptually ultimately like my problem
is
with bitcoin specifically yeah well it
sounds like i probably would agree with
you okay i'm going to be quiet alana go
ahead
really interesting thing about value
which has been particularly fascinating
where cryptocurrency is concerned
is that somebody just saying something
about cryptocurrency can influence the
value of cryptocurrency so like when kim
kardashian or maybe it was
kylie jenner one of those lot uh tweeted
something
about bitcoin we were living in a
simulation if that is it increased
um and there was a did massively i guess
like a
a 10 drop recently and it was just
because and this is
a cnbc business article saying
they believe the reason that it recently
dropped is just because elon musk
tweeted saying that said btc and eth do
seem high which is bitcoin
and ethereum and so the price has
dropped i think that it's also
that like implied in here that the
recent spikes are because that's weird
that you would tweet that
massively invested that's the thing is
is one thing that i'm a great business
person wild about it exactly if you want
them to like he's been tweeting all this
dogecoin stuff to the extent that i was
reading a business analyst article that
thinks that
dogecoin is protected because it has a
meme shield
people will not oversell because they
think there is a shield on owning this
particular coin because there's a meme
around it
created by elon musk so he has he has
infiltrated the cryptocurrency market to
such an extent
that he can control how much money
control
really courtesy or really stupid i can't
work out which one that is because that
seems really smart on some level he
would have lost money by tweeting that
not smart
it was eight percent drop very well
maybe i would say like maybe most people
three-dimensional chess in some way it's
maybe a while yeah maybe maybe
you wanted to buy a bitcoin is it just
by the right people talking about it
that's true of all stocks for the record
like i i
my um my i used to watch my
my my 90 year old cousin when i would go
over to her apartment for dinner in in
new york when i lived there
she became this obsessive day trader as
like a way to kind of occupy her mind
and so she would watch like cnbc for
like four hours straight and watch all
these financial analyst shows with like
jim cramer and people like that
larry kudlow et cetera et cetera and
they those guys on those programs were
always very keenly aware that when
callers would call in and say hey i got
a question about such and such stock
it's like the heisenberg uncertainty
principle by virtue of them having a
conversation
about it on their widely watched tv
program they
in in in the evaluation of its value
they will impact its value
we've changed games forever
i i tell you what i think we'll have
some comments on this i can tell you
that i'm this
i can tell you i'm this close to
generating business for a kidney
specialist
so i uh that might be my my way of
saying uh
two hours later you all let's wrap it up
here i don't know how you still have a
job now alana i think i think that uh i
think they've fired you
yeah yeah i've been fired for these two
these two hours it's done for me um
thank you all for watching we are not
experts uh we just like talking to each
other about things
we are scientists though apparently god
damn right we are cause we can do
experiments
i do i do love this i do i do love this
because uh
bitcoin in particular uh since it's
something that i just i always every
time it comes up i go
i should someday learn more about that
uh and i just my
days are too full and i keep kicking it
down the road so i have written many
disabilities you would like to see them
i used to cover cryptocurrency at itunes
please boring
it's hard to make that stuff interesting
i'm being honest
it's difficult to do and that's the
ending that's the perfect dancing
genuinely um i'll see you all next week